what is so important is that
from i think the private sector has a
role
to be looking for more businesses at
least as an investor
to be looking for more businesses that
are still using technology
still software based or technology-based
businesses but that are
scaling employment for empathetic or
human type
work and there's a bunch of new ones
that i hope will be created
we backed a company called papa that's
doing very well that's it's grandkids on
demand
which sounds silly but with 10 000
boomers retiring every day
and and definitely not anywhere close to
10 000 like home health
workers starting jobs every day there's
a huge need for
empathetic people who can spend an hour
at a time
with the elderly doing everything from
like helping them with their netflix to
just talking to them right loneliness is
actually an epidemic
and has health consequences and so
health plans are more motivated than
ever
to bring on these papa pals to take time
to be with their patients to be with
their members because it improves their
health outcomes
because it actually helps bring more
sort of
data and feedback into the whole
conversation because they actually can
say like oh you need to go to the doctor
like let me let me drive you to the
doctor let me go help you pick up your
medicine like that
that solves a problem that we're not i
personally don't think we're ever gonna
have
empathetic like truly empathetic robots
um
elon begs to differ on that one but
for the time being there are still these
jobs that are the domain of humans and
should always be
uh that are very we're gonna
we have to delve into this alexis
humanity as medicine
humanity as elder care like that that's
staggeringly simple and profound
and important at the same time uh like i
i want to hear more it's called
papa p-a-p-a yeah p-a-p-a um and join
papa.com
is the website um but what the ceo so
what andrew
realized was this didn't exist as a type
of work
because it's not these are not medical
professionals these are not home health
care aides who are doing
you know drug administration and stuff
these are just empathetic
kind people and they go through diligent
screening process a lot of them are
actually
sort of college age students who are in
or learning medical professions so if
you are in nursing school
you want to make some good money on the
side instead of
say working that retail job at comp usa
you're a papa pal
because it's actually helping you
develop the skills that are valuable for
your career that only a human can do
and it's work where you come home every
day feeling amazing like i also
i also worked at a pizza hut for a
number of years as a cook and a waiter
like if i could have been a papa pal
instead of a pizza hut cook i sorry
pizza i would have taken that
10 times over like i didn't have to
smell like pizza every day at the end of
the work i could
smell like lavender or whatever the
whose folks his homes smell like
and and actually feel really good about
the work i did and make make good money
i think you know his instinct
and it's only this company's only a
couple of years old it's made great
progress so far tracking very well and i
think it is only a matter of time or in
the next five years
this will be a career option because the
market will have properly valued this
time
and the expertise who are great at it
that you can make a living as a you know
papa pal like this will be a profession
and it will be
something that like as a society will
already value because
my god we don't do enough to support our
seniors like it's easy
society is all very quick to be like
that's a good idea
and and then once the dollars follow
that where
you know off far too often we have a lot
of these jobs where everyone agrees it's
a great idea and really important but
the dollars aren't there
he's going to make the dollars get there
and
an entirely new class of people who
you know are growing up and
we could talk about higher education
maybe they decide that higher ed
you know and the costs of incurring that
assuming that doesn't change
the debt that they would take on isn't
worth it and really what they want to do
is just help people and help the elderly
and this is a path to actually make a
great living
awesome everyone knows that they're that
we have an aging population
and like you said like 10 000 people a
day and
um in in some idyllic vision that many
of these older americans
are in pleasant community retirement
facilities and homes and they have
grandkids that visit them on the regular
and all this stuff but now in covid
uh even if you had grandkids who wanted
to visit you they're not going to
uh so then the need for companionship
and help and you know human company and
contact
agree that it has a very
crucial health benefits so even on that
level you'd be like well it's probably
gonna help
maintain this person's um like
functionality for
extra x number of years so under the
papa model
who is paying so you can do
direct so i like you or i could sign up
and just do
sort of the direct to consumer it's like
hey come come visit my grandpa
every week and it's just build no
problem
um but where the real growth is is
actually from health plans
so health plans and these are folks who
are very very motivated
to keep their patients well right
and and it turns out for them it's
invaluable
because the more of this companionship
they can create the more this assistance
they create
the healthier the outcomes are right
we're we're only starting to scratch the
surface
on loneliness as an epidemic but the the
papers are getting published there's a
real health cost
there's a lonely installation yeah and
we're seeing it
i think now we all got a dose of it
right during covet and the lockdowns
there are a lot of folks who are really
way more empathetic with the idea of an
isolated senior than they have ever been
myself included right and so it sounds
like the pop-up pal
is meant to visit them in person um so
is there a ratio
where it's like 80 digital like uh you
know one visit a week like
what does that activity set look like so
this is an example every okay if you
ever
a good question ask every company next
year
and venture investors are already asking
this question which is how did covet
affect your business
and what was the like the
there is going to be a very just like
that k shaped recovery in the economy
broadly
there are really it's at the extremes
businesses either
had five years of what was going to be
steady growth and adoption
compressed into five months of rapid
growth
or the opposite papa ended up being one
of the former
they had virtual companionship as a
small part
of their business starting out and
kovid only accelerated the adoption so
now they're
they're majority virtual so it started
out a couple of years ago building the
software so that
like as a papa pal i could open my phone
have my appointment scheduled hit a
button and like you know i'd see on the
map where i'd drive
to go visit their home and it would that
was a very you know
physical in-person setup but
covet accelerated the adoption of
virtual companionship and so that is the
dominant one now
and you know for a generation of boomers
in particular
they're all everyone's armed with a
smartphone now um you know the last
10 years in particular have brought
adoption to a level where yeah
you know a lot of folks are very
comfortable with
zoom and face time that we never would
have expected
um a lot faster um thanks to this sort
of necessity of this and
and and pop has been a great beneficiary
of it and yeah it turns out
even the virtual companionship has the
same outcomes
uh for patients um which is something
like i this is something i can't
and this is another one where i think i
take for granted having founded reddit
but i can't unsee how
real relationships are even when they
are digital
even when they are total strangers even
when you don't even know what the person
looks like
because i've seen that happen for 15
years on a platform where all you know
is a username
and the text they write so if that
exists and it's very strong and in some
cases stronger i mean there are
there are people on the internet who
don't know anything about
fluffybunny16 other than that's their
username and yet they have a closer
relationship with them
than the people they see at the office
or normally would see at the office
every day
well i hope it's been established that
you can build very very strong
relationships
online digitally uh in in different ways
i mean heck there's that movie
uh her with uh joaquin phoenix like
falling in love with
his phone which i did not find to be
that implausible
like you know uh and and so
so to use uh the consumer facing
um model as an example let's say that
i'm a very busy
parent um i'll use myself screw it
personally so let's say i'm a very busy
parent i've got parents who are aging
i can just sign up i can be like hey
great news uh
i've got some papa pal like for you and
then you like
pick them up so you can get it as like a
gift for your
aging relatives and then they would just
have someone who could
minister to their um tech questions and
because
i will say as a an adult um i get tech
questions randomly from my parents
from my stepmom about which macbook she
should buy
and yeah i know i and it's it's tough
too because like i want to be
i want to be a good kid but i'm also
like just google it
you don't need to ask
[Laughter]
like that and and you know another
interesting thing that i wouldn't have
expected i gave i gave andrew
a hard time because he had a 1-800
number on his website
back he was just starting out and we
were leading that round and i was like
really a 1-800 number and he's like you
don't understand like
this is the way to do it yeah you can
sign up through the website
but you put the 1900 number trust me
because it's going to help
so much with with um onboarding and he's
been absolutely right
um so yeah if you wanted to schedule the
1-800 the
pop-up file you could do it online or
download the app or you could also just
call one another number because for a
lot of their
customers that's the most comfortable
way to do it and
it's that that little thing
like my my naivete arrogance in that
moment of like really a 1-800 number
that is why i love entrepreneurship
because
the founder the ceo he knew
he had to be humble enough to
go to where his users were or to build
something that
people actually wanted and
you know the founders who are successful
are the ones who can break out of their
own bias and actually empathize
and like so in that moment as an
investor i was clearly not empathizing
well
but but that's one of the things that is
um i think so needed right now
because we have so many big problems to
solve
so many and the private sector can't do
all of it let me also say i don't think
the private sector can do all of it
but there are areas where we need entire
industries to cr
to be invented we need yeah a career
like being a papa pal to be invented
and and there's countless more because
we need alternatives for those jobs
that are gonna get largely automated and
and i'm i i know this is not the entire
solution but it's a big part of it
and and that's that's really the impetus
behind why i do what i do now because i
need to help as many of those things get
started as possible
to me the ideal vision alexis is that
the government helps create incentives
for the creation of these jobs and
industries
you know what i mean because like right
now you look at it and you can find
uh an opportunity like papa pal where
there there's enough
money currently heading into it where
you can actually build a business around
it
uh but there are other things where you
look and say ooh that should exist
um but there aren't the monetary
incentives in place right now
uh and this is where a lot of the
you know um sustainability efforts go
it's like well we all can see that we
should be investing in
uh sustainable energy uh products but
sometimes the money's not there because
hey guess what fossil fuel is really
cheap right now and the rest of it so
like the ideal situations the government
actually helps create the incentive so
that people like you can invest in
the innovators and entrepreneurs who
want to try and build these things
um even papa pal when i think about it
why i was pressing on the
the uh business model and the revenues
where to me the social need for
papa pals uh is sky high
and then the question is whether uh the
folks that need a
papa pal have a health care health plan
provider that's
smart enough to buy it have relatives
that are smart enough to buy and have
the resources to do so
uh you know you can imagine a world
where the government was like you know
what
like i'm not saying papa pals the way
but like
we're gonna have like uh you know some
stipend for anti-loneliness measures and
you can do whatever you want with them
you can
you know talk to friends family you can
like use a subscription service
like this i mean there is a world where
we can actually start throwing
uh higher levels of resources at some of
these problems but i
couldn't agree with you more that it's
innovators and entrepreneurs that
hopefully will
uh will give rise to the jobs we need
thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you